هذا احد اكبر واشهر واقدم محال السوبر
ماركت في مدينه يوديس وهذا هو حاله بعد
الهجوم الذي استهدف المدينه ليله الامس
تقول القياده العسكريه هنا
بانفت بخمسه عشره مسيره من نوع شاهد
ايرانيه بالاضافه الى ثمان صواريخ من نوع
كاليبر تقول ايضا القياده العسكريه بانها
تمكنت من اسقاط وافشال كل هذه المحاولات
لكن شظايا احد الصواريخ سقطت فوق هذا
المحل محل السوبر ماركت في حوالي الساعه
الرابعه فجرا وبالتالي كان هناك فقط ثلاث
اصابات داخل هذا المكان وربما لو كان هذا
الهجوم في النهار ربما كان هناك كارثه
انسانيه لان هذا المكان عاده ما يكون مكتظ
جدا بالرواد طبعا هذا المكان هذا محل
السوبر ماركت لا يبعد سوى تقريبا اثنين
كيلو متر عن ميناء اوديسا وبالتالي
الترجيحات بان ربما هذه الصواريخ كانت
تستهدف هذا الميناء طبعا منذ خروج روسيا
من اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب استهدفت تقريبا كل
الموانع موانئ اوديسا سواء البحريه او
النهريه وبالتالي يعتقد الكثيرون بان هذا
هو استمرار لمسلسل الاستهدافات ايضا
الكثير يتحدث عن ان هذا الهجوم هو ايضا
استمرار لمسلسل ما وصفوه بالتحذيرات خصوصا
بعد ان قررت اوكرانيا تفعيل وتحديد ممرات
بحريه في البحر الاسود للسفن التجاريه
بعيدا عن اي موافقه روسيه ويبدو انه في ظل
هذا التدافع ستستمر الهجمات على مدينه
اوديسا الجزيره